la réalité c'est que cette région aurait
dû faire beaucoup plus sur la question
de la santé deux chiffres qui le
démontre le budget santé aujourd'hui
c'est 0,1 pour cent du fonctionnement et
ses moins d'un pour cent si madame belga
vous savez d'ailleurs parfaitement
régionales vous pouvez le contester ça
peut vous déplaire même si de temps en
temps sur que les autres régions ont
fait mieux que titania ça ne fait pas
mal d'entendre des vérités oui d'autres
régions ont fait mieux que l'occitanie
mais je voudrais sortir de la polémique
qui s'installe comme souvent d'ailleurs
entre madame delga et monsieur garoupe
pour faire des propositions dès le début
de cette campagne
le premier axe sur lequel je me suis
engagé avec mon équipe c'est la santé
d'abord en ayant une deuxième sur ma
liste
deuxième femme qui est une sage femme
c'est un symbole plus qu'un symbole
parce que dans nos propositions faire de
la santé des femmes une priorité c'est
pour nous essentiel nous avons fait une
proposition très clair moi je ne crois
pas au recrutement de 200 médecins la
région d'abord site
c'est un enfumage c'est de la pure de la
poudre de perlimpinpin
parce que personne ne peut aujourd'hui
recruter 200 m s'est même pas même les
oasis et le patronne du circuit
d'algarve en a qui disent ils se
trouvent
gardez votre calme il se trouve que le
président que le président du syndicat
des médecins libéraux
jérôme marty avec qui j'ai fait la
présentation des propositions de santé
dit à quel point votre proposition ne
tiennent pas la route
la proposition je fais est la suivante
au terme de mon mandat de président de
région de ses six ans plus aucun
habitant de notre région ne sera plus de
30 minutes de la prise en charge d'une
urgences cardiaques ou d'une urgence
mais est ce que vous pensez
philosophiquement que la région voulait
n'est pas adapté à ses besoins c'est
philosophiquement que la région doit
faire plus c'est ce qu'on doit
décentraliser les compétences régionales
sur téva questions vont termine
permettez de films
je ne suis pas un philosophe je suis un
acteur politique la réalité c'est quand
même délicat ne supporte pas qu'on
conteste son bilan qui est mauvais sur
le sujet sauf qu'il est mauvais nous
faisons des propositions en équipant des
lieux de proximité avec des dispositifs
de télémédecine qui existent notamment
pour les urgences aujourd'hui qui
permettront en proximité de s'assurer
qu'aucun nos habitants soit plus de 30
minutes d'une prise en charge d'urgence
cardiaque ou d'urgence de maternité
notamment avec des maisons obstétrique
de proximité voulait quand c'est très
concret il est c'est très sérieux toi
j'ai 35 ans et j'ai la chance d'être
député de mon pays je suis allée enfants
du lot un député de droite dans une
terre de
ch j'ai la chance de servir à
l'assemblée nationale des causes
auxquelles je crois c'est de la
protection des femmes et des enfants
victimes de violence de violence celle
du handicap et je pense que notre région
a besoin d'une nouvelle génération
politique voilà 25 ans que ce sont les
mêmes en monopole qui gère cette région
des socialistes il est temps d'avoir une
autre étape
je ne suis pas une girouette politique
je ne suis pas un touriste ou un
parachute et politique comme d'autres
candidats ici qui s'intéresse à tous
sauf l'année dans notre région et je
souhaite consacrer toutes mes forces
tout montrer nettement énergie celle de
la nouvelle génération pour que la vie
demain soit meilleur dans notre région